hello everyone and welcome back to the
chessable Masters 2024 of the Champions
Chester it is Magnus Carlson versus ala
fuja and today they had a match the
Grand Final H where alza defeated Magnus
Carlson but as alza started off from the
losers bracket and then he requalified
into the winners bracket uh that does
not mean a lot okay he defeated Magnus
once but now he must defeat him again uh
for example if Magnus defeated alza then
the match will be over but if alza
defeats then we have this so think soal
the grand reset and then they have to
play another match consisting of two
rapid games so the first match was uh
incredibly played by Ala he won the
first two games and got a draw in the
third one which means that he clinched
the match without Magnus taking a single
point uh but now there's a different
match so let's see what happened here uh
Magnus in the first game uh has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn to
D4 uh in the uh in the match that he
lost before this game in in game one and
game three he first played the the P G3
and also in the other game he played the
London system but here we have D4 Knight
to F6 and Bishop to G5 uh he opts for
the trpovski attack so he needs to try
something different as uh well he just
didn't get any anything going with the
the previous attempts uh we have pa uh
sorry Pawn to D5 and now Pawn to E3 Pawn
to C5 uh and uh Knight to D2 so nothing
new here all been seen before Knight to
C6 C3 and C captures on D4 we have e
captures on D4 and pawn to H6
challenging the bishop Bishop goes back
and now Bishop to F5 uh Knight G2 F3
Pawn to E6 nicely putting pawns and
light squares as you've developed your
bishop and now the dark Square Bishop is
free to roam in between Bishop to E2 and
now Bishop to D6 we have castles and
there is a game where castles was played
but here we have Queen to C7 by Ala uh
and it is now as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game uh so here Bishop
to G3 as uh well this Pawn could uh come
under attack if the Knight moves so
Bishop to G3 and all is a Trad we have
Bishop captures Pawn captures and pawn
to H5 now alza starts the king side
attack as Magnus has Castle King side
alza will most likely Castle Queen side
uh Rook to E1 now comes Pawn to G6 uh
and Knight to F1 the Knight is very
useful here you know the the position
will open up and with the black queen on
C7 and the black Rook on h8 you could
easily get checkmated here but with the
two knights uh you know it's not going
to be that easy so okay Knight to G4 and
now Queen to D2 by Magnus we have Queens
side castles bya and now Magnus starts
his expansion on the queen side of
course Pawn to B4 King to B8 and pawn to
A4 we have Pawn to F6 uh and now Knight
to H4 putting pressure on the bishop
here G5 five uh forcing the trade Knight
captures on F5 we have e captures and
Bishop to D3 and okay uh one Knight has
been eliminated but here uh is the
problem for alera with Magnus having the
Knight on F1 uh he can't just start the
attack with with let's say Pawn to H4
because after Bishop captures on F5 and
let's say captures on G3 uh he's just
going to take the free piece and after
captures on F2 Queen captures there is
no mate uh the Knight on F1 is is one
tricky bastard so after Bishop to D3 we
have Knight to E7 H and now Pawn to F3
kicking way it is is Knight Knight to H6
and now Rook to E6 putting pressure on
the F6 Pawn but also on Black's Queen
side Rook H to f8 defending the pawn and
Rook eight to E1 doubling up attacking
the Knight on E7 so Knight to C8 getting
the Knight out of the way and now Pawn
to A5 Magnus just continues advancing
his pawns on the queen side Knight to D6
and now Pawn to A6 we have Pawn to B6 of
course you do not want to open up your
king uh and Knight to
E3 uh we have Queen to D7 now putting
pressure on that Rook as the Knight is
in between the Rooks uh and the Knight
captures on D5 we have Knight to E4
trying to be tricky here now the Rooks
are disconnected again and he wants to
play Queen captures on E6 but Magnus has
something else in mind Rook captures on
B6 with check he already grabbed the
pawn now he grabs another pawn and he
will collect the Knight on e4 a captures
and E captures on E uh F captures on e4
uh we have King to A7 uh not allowing
the pawn to be Advanced any further and
now Pawn to B5 you could also start with
C4 first uh but uh yeah he goes Pawn to
B5 with have F captures and E4 Bishop
captures and now Queen captures on B5
but it's not a problem you don't have to
worry about ever losing the A6 Pawn then
the position opens up and that's going
to be a problem so Pawn to C4 uh like I
said if Capt you you'll just play Queen
B2 and then Rook to A1 becomes a huge
problem so Queen to A5 offering a queen
trade and Knight B4 threatening Knight
to C6 check to pick up the the black
queen Rook to C8 and here Magnus goes
for uh the queen trade Knight to C6 with
check a more precise way of handling
this would be just Pawn to C5 there's H
you cannot capture because if you
capture the pawn no longer defends the
queen and then Knight to C6 check Forks
the king and the queen but also the
queen uh comes under attack and you just
win the queen uh so there's really no
good move for black here and it it
improves White's position drastically uh
but okay he did have a well Magnus had
two and a half minutes on the clock alza
had 18 seconds on the clock as these are
rapid games 10 minutes per player and
ala was really struggling here so he
went for the quick trade Knight to C6
check Rook captures you have to trade
Queen captures and now B captures on A5
Bishop captures on C6 and now Knight to
F5 so okay Magnus wins back the exchange
and now uh it's time not not Knight to
F7 Knight to F5 was played and now Pawn
to D5 he starts advancing his pawns and
he does have two connected pass pawns
also a Pawn on A6 not for long King
captures on A6 and now Pawn to C5 uh
Rook to d8 and now Rook to E6 uh
threatening some nasty discoveries here
so Knight to D4 attacking the bishop and
the rook and here Magnus plays the
beautiful Bishop to A4 check a discovery
with an exchange sacrifice but you
cannot take the Rook if you take the
Rook captures and then the pawn is
Unstoppable uh the Bishop from A4 guards
the E8 Square so instead after Bishop to
A4 King to A7 was played now comes Rook
E7 check King to B8 uh and pawn to D6 we
have Rook to C8 putting pressure on the
C5 Pawn but now Rook to E4 going after
the Knight interestingly you can even
play C6 here uh it's just a funny
position that I will I want to show you
because uh well if capture with the Rook
then Bishop captures Rook but if capture
with the Knight then Bishop captures
Rook captures and now Rook d8 with check
and the pawn and Rook are shouldering of
the the black king and after we move the
king then D7 and d8 becomes a queen you
will have to give up your Rook for the
uh for the past Pawn so that's why you
could play it but okay Rook D4 also
winning uh and now Knight to F5 we have
King to F2 getting the king into the
game Rook captures on C5 but now Rook to
E8 with check a similar idea as the king
cannot approach the Pawn King to B7 and
pawn to D7 now we have Rook to D5 d8
becomes a queen Rook captures and d8
Rook captures and he was in this
position on move 48 that um ala fuja
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so Magnus won this
game very nicely H he's up a full Rook
so of course that's why ala resigned and
now alza must win on demand to to bounce
back in the match uh now let's see what
happened in that one it's also a very
nice game here alza had the white pieces
and he started with Pon to E4 we have
Pawn to E5 by Magnus Knight F3 Knight to
C6 and Bishop to C4 going for the
Italian game uh Knight to F6 the the two
knights defense and now Pawn to D3 the
modern Bishop's opening not of course
everyone's favorite Knight to G5 we very
rarely see that Bishop to C5 and now
Bishop to G5 we have Pawn to H 6 Bishop
to H4 Bishop back to E7 and now Bishop
to G3 putting pressure on E5 so D6 A4
and now Pawn to A5 stopping further ad
advancement castles castles and now Rook
to E1 and there is a game uh where
Knight the H7 was played preparing Pon
well preparing moving the king and Ponto
F5 was a classical game even uh from the
2021 Russian championship between
Andreas seeno and Alexander prka uh but
um uh
yeah that game ended in a draw Knight H7
was played but here we have Pawn to G6
by Magnus and it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game so
okay Pawn to H3 Rook to E8 and now
Knight to C3 with have Bishop back to f8
and Bishop to H4 putting pressure on the
black queen here so Bishop to G7 and now
Knight to D5 piling up on the Knight
Bishop to E6 and now C3 we have Bishop
captures on D5 Magnus gives up the
bishop to uh you know ease the pressure
a little bit Bishop captures and pawn to
G5 now uh Bishop captures on C6 first by
Ala we have B captures and now Bishop to
G3 and Magnus claims the semiopen B file
puts pressure on the B2 pawn queen to C2
and now Knight to H5 he wants to put the
Knight on F4 and alza goes for Bishop to
H2 Knight to F4 and now Pawn to D4
striking in the center uh and the queen
to F6 Magnus wants to attack ala's King
but alza is defending properly D
captures an E5 D captures and Knight to
D2 now where uh interestingly uh Magnus
played Queen to E6 but he has he had a
line that uh forces a draw uh and uh
that would win him the match I'm going
to show it because it's really really
disgusting it's Rook captures on B2 and
the reason for that is that after Knight
to D3 well Queen captures obviously
after Knight to D3 attacking the queen
and the F2 Pawn uh turns out there is
nothing better than to draw the game
Queen B1 Queen captures an F2 check King
to H1 you will collect the Knight on D2
and also put pressure on The Rook here
and after Rook to F1 uh Knight to F2
check and now if you if you capture then
black will be a little bit better and
push for the win uh so best would be to
just play King back to G1 and then you
repeat Knight to D3 the threat is Queen
E3 check so you have to uh you have to
move back King to H1 Knight F2 check and
we would have a repetition here with
Magnus winning the event but he didn't
he played Queen to E6 uh and okay the
game continues ala realizes something
could be happening here he plays Pawn to
B3 uh and Bishop to f8 now Shifting the
bishop over to this diagonal uh Knight
to C4 and Bishop to C5
now uh it's it's a pawn sacrifice but
now after Knight captures on A5 uh
Magnus continues the attack on the king
Side Pawn to G4 H but now Pawn to H4 ala
does not allow the opening of the
position we Knight to H5 uh and now King
back to H1 it's very important to get
the King off of this diagonal because as
long as the king is here you can't play
moves like uh Bishop to G3 or G3 because
the Knight just captures it you will not
be able to capture back with the F Pawn
so King H1 we have Queen to F6 and now
Bishop to G3 Knight captures and G3 F
captures and queen to F2 so Magnus
putting a lot of pressure on on ala but
still ala's position is to be preferred
here Queen captures Bishop captures
attacks the rook and the pawn and now
Rook e to B1 preparing to advance the
Queens side pawns we have Pawn to F5 by
Magnus and now ala sort of trusted
Magnus here uh and uh he played Pawn to
B4 usually the absolute best move in any
position but here it's better to bring
the Rook back to F1 point is that F5 is
the Target and after Rook to F1 you have
to defend the bishop you will capture
here and then it's a free Pawn uh well
you've traded pawns but you really don't
care about the double G pawn and this
Pawn is very important uh but ala
trusted him he played Pawn to B4 now
comes Rook B Rook B to d8 and Knight
captures in C6 Magnus goes Rook to D6
attacks the Knight and pawn to B5 F
captures on e4 uh Rook to
B4 uh putting pressure on the E4 pawn
and now Pawn to E3 Magnus has a pass
pawn and he wants to push it all the way
to E2 and E1 uh and now Rook to E E4 B
it is a stopping Pawn to E2 now
interestingly uh this is with a little
time on the clock L had a minute and a
half Magnus had almost four minutes uh
pretty impossible to solve uh but I will
show it to you uh the point is that uh
Rook to E4 is the best move but not
right away you have to play Rook captur
and G4 check first and it looks like a a
move only uh a beginner would play you
know grab a pawn give a check and you
have to be a 2800 player like ala to not
play it but you know it's actually what
you have to do and the reason for that
is uh after the king moves if it moves
to the f file then even better but if
King to H7 then you move the Rook back
to E4 and now look at this Rook to D2
you you guard E2 Square you want to
advance the pawn to E2 now comes Rook to
F1 and after Rook to f8 there's this
Rook captures an E3 move and that's the
problem that's how you eliminate the
past pawn and now white is winning again
and the reason for that Rook to G4 check
was to kick the king away uh from the
defense of the Rook on f8 if the King
was on G7 defending the Rook then there
is no Rook captures on E3 because you
just take the free rook and The Rook
captures King captures uh but yeah you
give Rook Rook to in this position where
ala thought yeah why would I just
capture this Pawn let's play Rook to E4
you know like a like a professional
chess player uh yeah it's actually the
best because it forces the king either
here or here or here or here uh you know
you can't go here and you will not be uh
defending the f8 square too much to ask
for of course with so little time on the
clock but it is what is needed and
that's why we analyze these games so
Rook to D2 and now comes Rook to F1 but
here Rook to f8 and The Rook is now very
safe here there is no Rook captures on
E3 uh so King to H2 and it was also in
this position on move 39 that ala fuja
lost on time that means Magnus wins both
games and Magnus is the winner of the
chess B Masters division one uh Grand
Final
reset now uh here it's of course
completely winning and you could uh uh
try try a lot of stuff here the problem
with capturing on G4 instead of King H2
also we we have to mention that if you
play this now King H7 uh you don't have
a rook on e4 to capture the pawn that's
the problem if you if you move it back
then just Bishop captures on G3 and you
still can't take it because if you take
it or even if you take the Rook here uh
then Rook D1 check you get checkmated uh
and yeah there there's nothing if you
capture this Pawn then Rook captures on
F1 is Checkmate um uh completely without
the moves and also after King H2 uh
where where ala lost in time uh the idea
is just E2 there there's really nothing
here once The Rook moves you will play
Rook to D3 and that's it whatever your
play loses if you take the pawn then
Bishop captures on G3 check King G1 only
move and Rook to D1 check Rook E1 and
Rook captures on E1 will be Checkmate so
uh brilliant brilliant first match by
Ala defeating Magnus with two and a half
to half but as alza said in an interview
after the game the first match doesn't
count and you know uh he was a little
bit sad but you know what what are you
going to do he played he played great
chess he defeated Magnus Carson in a
match uh just not in the one that uh
that mattered uh so yeah great stuff by
both of them uh this time Magnus emerges
Victorious uh so that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it I will show you uh
the the game Sala uh one against Magnus
um after this probably tomorrow uh and
of course if you guys have anything else
that you would like to suggest also use
hashtag suggestion as I believe tomorrow
there are no active events uh so you
know uh anything goes uh and yeah I
would like to thank Jeremy anios Carl
Weinberg rajashri churi Brian Stone and
David gasparian for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day